all right joining us now it's with more
reaction to breaking news Muller as
agreed to testify is Senate Judiciary
Committee chairman Lindsey Graham
yesterday by the way you asked you said
the American people must be able to see
it all I agree and you can make it
happen but it was your key question to
the Attorney General that I have played
over and over again I don't have time
with all the news right well but I
played it probably between radio and TV
60 times and the question was crucial
because you asked for all these did
Robert Muller have the resources did he
have the time did he have this Yeah
right you strike are you certain then
you said do you care about a Rik
possibly rigged investigation FISA abuse
I'll let you take it from there
well bottom line is after all you're
looking and all the time you had all the
money you spent did Trump collude with
the Russians no do you stand by your
report yes did you turn it over to the
Attorney General to decide about
obstruction and the eternal Attorney
General said I did and I'm not going to
revisit it so it is case closed for me
so they can do anything they want to in
the house and I think it'll blow up in
their face I think though let's go back
to some of the other questions how do
you justify hiring Hillary's attorney
only Democrats I'd Andrew Weissman did
he couldn't find one Republican one blow
up in their face this will blow up in
her face the conclusions can't change
there is no collusion that's what told
them thing was about to begin with
there's nobody on earth could could
bring an obstruction case based on these
facts the president gave 1.4 million
documents to Muller McCann his lawyer
testified for 30 hours he made everybody
available to Muller that Muller wanted
to talk to and he submitted question
answered questions in writing so this
President did nothing to stop Muller
from finding the truth if you go back I
mentioned to Jay Sekulow that nine and a
half minute press conference he did and
boy the media was so quick they thought
they thought that conspiracy theory came
back to life it's serious and
significant though right I watched it
and I was like number one I knew he had
said the opposite waiting for people to
catch out right
number two when you think about the
attorney I thought the Attorney General
bar was being very gracious to the
special counsel and threw him a lifeline
they released a joint statement
basically say I didn't mean what I said
for nine and a half minutes
that's that ought to be very troublesome
but Robert Muller
latkas right but I hope people
understand what you're talking about
because when Muller came in to tell Barr
that he couldn't decide he couldn't make
a decision about obstruction he was
going to leave it to bar and bar asked
him point-blank is this because of the
DOJ policy you don't indict a sitting
president he said no he said complicated
facts and complicated law would not
allow him to reach a conclusion so after
two years and X amount of dollars and
FBI agents if he couldn't decide on
obstruction of justice why do you think
you know Baro would reach a different
conclusion other than you can't
prosecute okay so let me go and I want
to ask you specifically because you were
the one saying it last week first of all
I am very happy you have pledged the
American people all of these issues
starting with the rigged investigation
and a Hillary Hillary okay and by the
way I don't think you delete subpoenaed
emails and clean the hard drive I would
say that's probably the best case of
obstruction of justice I've ever seen
but it's only only matters if it's
Donald Trump but you're gonna go back to
the beginning right tell us what else
specifically you're interested in that
you will get to the bottom of okay all
right here though honestly the Horowitz
report about did the DOJ and FBI defraud
the FISA Court did they lie to the FISA
Court to get a warrant against Carter
page I want to find out why they opened
the counterintelligence investigation
against Trump and I really do believe
the only reason Clinton wasn't charged
with anything discuss if you wanted her
to win how do you charge her with a
crime in the middle of the campaign you
know these you know these are really
good questions and I think the Phi's
abuse is a tip of the iceberg but think
about this we already know what
Christopher Steele is going to say he's
ready said it in an interrogatory here's
the big question so in January of 2017
there's james comey and trump tower
saying well we have this dossier
it's salacious but it's unburied 17
before he becomes president October 2016
he signs the first FISA application that
we now know because of Steele's
testimony I have no idea of any of its
true under threat of perjury means it's
an unverifiable document at the top of a
FISA warrant I've been told I've never
seen one it actually says verified now
the question is does that sound like a
premeditated fraud on the FISA Court
judges and does that we know Comey lied
alighted in October 2016 to January 2017
he but he had to lie in October 2016
because steel undercuts his story right
so what we know is McCabe said without
the dossier they'd be no Warren against
Carter page here's the question to ask
anybody is the dossier verified to this
day we now know that you know Steele
said I don't know if it's true or not
Comey tells the president in January
2017 717 is a salacious unverified it's
the same document they said was reliable
and trustworthy in October it doesn't
add up the the dossier is a bunch of
garbage I can tell you without any doubt
it's a bunch of garbage and it was used
to get a warrant against American
citizen and somebody's going to be held
accountable for that all right senator
Graham great to see you by the way oh
trey gowdy said he's going to treat us
to halls the same because come on my
show only when jason Chaffetz is hosting
trey Gowdy is a great guy yeah but I'll
believe it when I see it I think we'll
all have to pay Hannity pays there's
gonna be some controversy somewhere
somebody's gonna you know write it up
I'd be in trouble
I couldn't see a senator thank you